हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल तो सबसे
पहले गुड इवनिंग टू
ल तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको
मेरी आवाज लाउड एंड
क्लियर सबको क्लियर सुनाई दे रही है मेरी
आवाज वेरी गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग
एवरीवन नहीं स्लो नहीं है नेट स्पेस पता
नहीं आप लोगों को लगता है कि मेरी आवाज
स्लो है बट मेरी आवाज स्लो नहीं
है मेरी आवाज स्लो नहीं
है अब्दुल मुझे टाइम नहीं मिला लिंक दिन
चेक करने का तो जैसे मैं चेक करता हूं
थोड़ा फ्री होगा तो मैं आपका लिंकन पर
रिप्लाई कर
दूंगा ओके तो आज कितने स्टूडेंट्स नए हैं
हमारे जो फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आ रहे
हैं ओके एनोनिमस आप फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में
आए हो
ओके तो कोई बात नहीं अगर जो फर्स्ट टाइम
क्लास में आए हैं तो हमारी जो वीडियो होती
है उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में हमेशा एक ट चैनल
का लिंक रहता है तो वहां पर आपको क्या
करना है सिंपली वहां पर जाकर जवाइन करना
है सो दैट कि वहां पर आपको अपडेट मिलते
रहे कि नेक्स्ट क्लास कब होगी और कुछ भी
अनाउंसमेंट होती है कु नई चीज आने वाली
होती है तो सारी चीजें आपको क्या प है
हमारे
ैनू आपको क्या करना है कि लिंक दिन पर
डेनिक्स अकेडमी आप सर्च करोगे तो वहां पर
भी आपको क्या है कि डे
फोनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी का डेफ अकेडमी
का वेब पेज मिल जाए मैं आपको सर्च करके
दिखा देता हूं यहीं पर यह रहा कि अ लि अभी
लिंक दिन पोस्ट मुझे ओपन करनी पड़ेगी आई
एम सॉरी फॉर दैट तो अभी नहीं कर सकता मैं
बट अगर डेनिक्स अकेडमी आप सर्च करोगे तो
वहां पर आपको डेफिनेटली डे फोनिक्स मिल
जाएगा मेरा फेस रिवील कब होगा तो आपको
मेरे फेस से मतलब है या मेरे क्लास से
मतलब है यह बताइए आप
लोग आप लोग मेरा चेहरा देखने आए हो या
क्लास में पढ़ने के लिए आए हो शायद मुझे
जो लगता है कि चेहरा मायने नहीं रखना
चाहिए किसी का
भी पढ़ाई मायने रखनी चाहिए
रियल वर्ल्ड प्रैक्टिकल कोई भी कंपनी आपको
करने देगी एनोनिमस एक काम करो आप एक
अप्रूव लेक आओ आप किसी भी कंपनी से कि
उनकी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करनी है और
हमारे सचिन सर है वह लाइव क्लास में
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करना चाहते हैं अपनी
क्लास में स्टूडेंट को सिखाना चाहते हैं
तो आप यह रिटर्न अप्रूवल दे दो तो वह
youtube3 टेस्टिंग भी हो जाएगी ऑफेंसिव
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग क्या यह आप अथॉरिटी
लेकर आ सकते
हो अगर आप यह अथॉरिटी लेकर आ सकते हो तो
हम लाइव कर
लेंगे रिटर्न अथॉरिटी होनी चाहिए आपके पास
तो आपको पहले प्रैक्टिस करनी आप सीख रहे
हो उसके बाद रियल वर्ल्ड में यह पोर्ट ओपन
नहीं मिलेंगे मैं आपके बाद से एग्री करता
हूं बट बात यह है कि रियल वर्ल्ड में
पोर्ट ओपन मिलते ही है रियल वर्ल्ड में एक
चीज ऐड हो जाती है आपके पास जब भी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते हो क्योंकि वो
एक एडवांस फेज होता है जहां पर आप
इंटरमीडिएट से बढ़ के प्रोफेशनल लेवल पर
जो पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग सीखते हो ना वहां
पर क्या होता है कि बीच में फायरवॉल्स
होते हैं एंटीवायरस होते हैं तो उनको इ
वेड करना वह आपको आना चाहिए तभी आप क्या
कर सकते हो किसी भी मशीन के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन और वह सारी चीजें परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो ओके तभी आप कर सकते हो लेकिन ऐसा
है कि सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन एन्यूमरेशन
ये सारी चीजें रियल वर्ल्ड में भी परफॉर्म
की जाती है पोर्ट और कुछ हो सकता है पोर्ट
के ऊपर सर्विस और कुछ रन कर सकती है जरूरी
नहीं कि एफटीपी और एफटीपी आपको मिल जाता
है रियल वर्ल्ड में ऐसा भी नहीं है कि
नहीं
मिलेगा ओके हम क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं
अभी तो ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे नाउ गो टू आवर
लैब नाउ अभी हमारा सेम लैब है जो लास्ट
क्लास में बाउंट हैकर जो लैब हम परफॉर्म
कर रहे थे जहां पर हमने क्या किया था कि
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन किया था टारगेट
आईपी के ऊपर टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस अलग है बट
लैब सेम है तो पोर्ट 21 पोर्ट 22 और पोर्ट
80 ओपन थे जिनके ऊपर जो सर्विस वर्जन है
वीएस एफटीपीडी है ओपन एसएसए है और अचे
एचटीटीपीडी है जिनका वर्जन के साथ आपके के
पास इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है तो हमने उसके
बाद क्या किया था नेक्स्ट स्टेप में जो
बेसिक वनटी स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था उससे
हमें कुछ ज्यादा खास इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली
थी देन हम एफटीपी और एसएसएस के ऊपर फर्द
एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करना चाहते हैं तो
एफटीपी पर हमने एक स्क्रिप्ट रन की थी कि
एफटीपी एनन उससे हमने यह फाइंड आउट यह पता
लगाया था कि जो यह यह मशीन है जो सीटीएफ
है इसका जो एफटीपी सर्वर है वह मिस
कॉन्फिडेंट एजिस्ट करती है टीपी एनोनिमस
मतलब क्या है कि आपको एफटीपी सर्वर के
अंदर लॉग इन करने के लिए किसी भी यूजर नेम
और पासवर्ड की जरूरत नहीं है पब्लिकली कोई
भी एक्सेस कर सकता है जस्ट आपको यूजर नेम
एनोनिमस यूजर यूज करना है और विदाउट
पासवर्ड आप क्या कर सकते हो एफटीपी सर्वर
को एक्सेस कर सकते हो तो अभी हम
डायरेक्टली एफटीपी सर्वर को एक्सेस करते
हैं लास्ट क्लास में हमने जो पढ़ा था तो
एफटीपी वो सिंपली कंट्रोल शिफ्ट v हिट
एंटर तो कनेक्टेड टू एनोनिमस ए एन एन वाई
एम ओ य एनोनिमस हिट एंटर हमने लॉगिन
सक्सेसफुल किया अभी हम क्या करते लिस्ट
आउट करते हैं इसके अंदर कौन-कौन सी फाइल
है
एलएस अभी य हमारे एफटीपी सर्वर यह जो
टारगेट मशीन है उसके एफटीपी सर्वर के साथ
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश कर रहा है देन उसके
बाद इस एफटीपी सर्वर के ऊपर जो भी फाइल्स
है जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है वह आप
लिस्ट आउट कर पाओगे वह देख पाओगे कौन सी
फाइल्स या कौन सी डायरेक्टरी अवेलेबल है
और एफटीपी क्या होता है और कैसे उसको हम
एक्सेस कर कर सकते हैं तो एन्यूमरेशन
पार्ट में पढ़ चुके हैं और एफटीपी रियल
वर्ल्ड में कैसे आपको देखने को मिल सकता
है यह भी मैं आपको डे 14 क्लास में डिस्कस
करके डिस्कस किया था हम हम सबने क्लास
में दे आर 26 स्टूडेंट्स ओनली तो सेम सेम
ऑन यू
गाइस सभी को किसी को सबको किसी में एफर्ट
में किसी को इंटरेस्ट नहीं है और किसी को
मेरी मेहनत की भी कदर नहीं
है तो कोई नहीं आप ऐसी चीजें मिस करोगे
अभी आपको लगता है कि ये जो बेसिक लैब है
आप लोगों को आती हैं मैं समझता हूं हो
सकता कुछ ऐसे टूल्स भी होंगे जो आपको पता
होंगे लेकिन बीच में अचानक से कभी कोई एक
ऐसी लैब परफॉर्म हो रही होगी जिसमें कोई
ऐसा टूल आएगा जो आपको नहीं पता होगा या
कुछ ऐसा कांसेप्ट आएगा जो आपको नहीं पता
होगा और किसी दिन आपको सच में उसकी जरूरत
पड़ गई किसी भी एग्जाम में किसी भी सीटीएफ
में या कोई भी आप पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
एग्जाम दे रहे हो सीएई जीपीटी या उसकी
एसीपी जैसे एग्जाम और वो छोटी सी गलती
आपके ऊपर कितनी भारी पड़ सकती है आप लोगों
को नहीं पता
विल टेक टाइम तो एक बार आपको पता चल जाएगा
कि कौन-कौन सी फाइल इसके ऊपर अवेलेबल है
तो आ ओके यह रहा इसके ऊपर दो फाइल्स
अवेलेबल है लॉक्स डटी एक्सटी और टास्क डॉट
टी एक्सटी अभी इन फाइल्स को हमें क्या
करना जब भी एफटीपी सर्वर के अंदर किसी भी
फाइल्स या डायरेक्टरी का आपको एक्सेस
मिलता तो आप क्या कर सकते हो उनको डाउनलोड
करना होगा उन फाइल्स या डायरेक्टरी को
अपनी मशीन के ऊपर ओके उन फाइल्स को अपनी
मशीन के ऊपर डाउनलोड करना होगा एफटीपी के
अंदर ऐसा कोई भी प्रोविजन नहीं है कि वहां
पर आप उसको देख पाओ कैट कर पाओ वहीं पर
उसको रीड कर पाओ ओके तो अभी हम क्या
करेंगे इनको डाउनलोड करेंगे डाउनलोड करने
के लिए गेट कमांड होती है गेट उसके बाद
लॉक्स डॉटी
हिट एंटर सक्सेसफुली डाउनलोड देन गेट य
हमारी मशीन में करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
जो करंट प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी है
जिसमें हम काम कर रहे हैं उसी के अंदर
डाउनलोड कर देंगे उसके बाद टास्क ड t एकटी
टास्क डटी एकटी हीट एंटर ओके कंप्लीटेड
अभी हम इसको क्या करते हैं इसके अंदर और
कोई इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल नहीं है और अगर आप
चाहो तो कौन-कौन सी कमांड मैं एफटीपी
सर्वर के अंदर यूज कर सकता हूं तो वो आप
पढ़ सकते हो हेल्प फाइल की यह रहा यह सारी
की सारी कमांड आप क्या कर सकते हो एफटीपी
सर्वर के ऊपर यूज कर सकते हो अभी के लिए
मैं एग्जिट करता हूं एफटीपी सर्वर से मुझे
एटीपी सर्वर की अब जरूरत नहीं है ओके तो
अभी ए एलस करते लिस्ट आउट तो हमारे पास
टास्क डटी एक्टी और हमारे पास यह रही एक
फाइल टास्क डटी एक्सटी अगर आपको और भी जदा
डिटेल्स में चाहिए एल एफन एल यह
रहा तो हमारे पास जो फाइल्स
है ओके एक मिनट क्लियर क्लियर क्लियर कर
देते हैं हम
यह रही एक तो टास्क डॉटी एक्सटी और आपकी
क्या है लक्स डटी एक्सटी अब इनको हम कैट
करके देखते हैं कि इनके अंदर क्याक
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है तो क्या करेंगे हम
कैट लक्स डटी एक्सटी हिट एंटर अभी यह
बताइए क्या इंफॉर्मेशन है मुझे कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है व्ट टाइप ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन दिस इज दिस आपको क्या लगता है
कि क्या इंफॉर्मेशन होगी
यह इंफॉर्मेशन आप लोगों को क्या लगता है
कि जो लक्स डटी एक्सटी जो फाइल मिली है
उसमें क्या है आप लोगों को क्या लगता है
यह सभी के सभी दे 30 स्टूडेंट्स तो आई
वांट आंसर फ्रॉम एवरीवन रंग और राइट आई
विल डिसाइड बट आई वांट आंसर फ्रॉम
एवरीबॉडी
ओके तो हम सोच सकते हैं किसी ने यहां पर
यूजर्स नेम या पासवर्ड या कॉमिनेशन ऑफ
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड कुछ भी हो सकता है इनको
क्या किया स्टोर करके रखा हुआ है अपनी
मशीन के अंदर अपने एफटीपी सर्वर की फाइल
के अंदर सेव करके ओके क्योंकि वल्नरेबल
मशीन है एक सीटीएफ है इसलिए आपके पास ये
फाइल है तो हम कह सकते हैं कि इट विल बी
मे बी यूजर नेम मे बी पासवर्ड और मे बी
कॉमिनेशन ऑफ द यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड ओके
यह दोनों दोनों ही चीज हो सकती है अभी हम
चेक करते हैं लकड य तो टास्क डटी एक्सटी
को टास्क डटी एक्सटी ट एंटर यह देखिए
प्रोटेक्ट विकस प्रोटेक्ट विकस प्लान फॉर
रेड आई पिक अप ऑन द मून और
लीन तो अब इस फाइल केर वैसे हमें कुछ भी
समझ में नहीं आ रहा कि यह क्या कहना चाह
रहे हैं बट यहां पर मुझे कुछ नेम्स दिखाई
दे जैसे कि
विकस रेड आई और लिन तो अभी सिंपली मेरे
पास देखिए जो लॉक्स एक्सटी फाइल है मुझे
नहीं पता उसके अंदर यूजरनेम है या पासवर्ड
है आई डोंट नो एनीथिंग जस्ट हम अम अजूम कर
रहे हैं कि उसके अंदर यूजरनेम भी हो सकते
हैं पासवर्ड भी हो सकते है कॉमिनेशन दोनों
दोनों कॉमिनेशन भी हो सक
जो टास्क डटी एक्सटी फाइल है उसके अंदर
हमें कुछ क्लज है की कुछ नाम जैसे लिन है
रेड आई है और विक कुछ तीन नाम आपको दिखाई
दे रहे हैं तो अभी बारबार कंफ्यूज होने की
बजाय हम सिंपली क्या कर रहे हैं कि इन
तीनों नामों को क्या करते हैं इस फाइल के
अंदर ऐड कर देते हैं यह जो फाइल ल इसके
अंदर ऐड कर देते कैसे ऐड करेंगे हम यह भी
देख लीजिए तो अभी मैं एक बार न्यू टब ओपन
कर देता हूं न्यू टैब के ऊपर एक
यह
रहा एक न्यू टर्मिनल
है
ओके दिस
वन यह रहा और अब इसको अभी क्या क्या करते
हैं विम या ननो करते हम चलो सिंपल नैनो
उसके बाद ड
एक्सटी और अभी हम क्या करते सबसे लास्ट
में ऐड
करेंगे दिस
वन
कॉपी यहां पर ऐड कर देते
हैं
पेस्ट देन रेड
आई कॉपी
एंड
पेस्ट दे उसके बाद
लिन लिन कंट्रोल एक्स और
यस हमने सक्सेसफुली सेव कर लिया एक बार
कैट आउट करके देखते लड्स यह रहा तो तीनों
यूजर नेम है जो भी नाम हमें यहां पर देखने
को मिल रहे थे टास्क डटी एक्सटी फाइल केर
हमने तीनों को सेव कर लिया एक फाइल के
अंदर ओके तीनों को एक फाइल के अंदर हमने
क्या कर लिया सेव कर
लिया अभी
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट अब हम क्या करें आप लोग
को क्या लगता अभी हमें क्या करना चाहिए
एफटीपी से रिलेटेड तो जो भी न्यूमरेशन
परफॉर्म करना था जो इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करनी थी वह हमने कर ली नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
स्टेप हमारा क्या होगा अभी हमें क्या करना
चाहिए बताइए एवरीवन बताइए नेक्स्ट हमें
क्या करना चाहिए
किसको डिक्रिप्ट
करोगे
बताइए नेट स्पेशलिस्ट बोल रहे हैं सर
डिक्रिप्ट वन बाय
वन ओके एचएच पी एनएम लैब्स का क्वेश्चन
देखना चाहिए नहीं मैं लैब्स के क्वेश्चन
सबसे लास्ट में सॉल्व करूंगा पूरी लैब को
सॉल्व करने के बाद
ब्रूट फोर्स ऑन एसएसए ओके नेक्स्ट अखिलेश
राव एचटीटी एन्यूमरेशन और
कोई
बताइए आप लोग 27 स्टूडेंट हो तो क्या आप
लोग आंसर नहीं कर
सकते बताइए
बताओ बताओ बताओ जल्दी से आंसर आंसर बताओ
कि हमें नेक्स्ट स्टेप क्या करना
चाहिए लास्ट लब हमने सॉल्व की थी
ना कौन सी फाइल ओपन करोगे
सोहन फाइल तो हमने ओपन किया ना
मैंने क्या नहीं किया यार मोहम्मद आप लोग
कंफ्यूज क्यों
हो यस हम क्या करेंगे एचटीटीपी एन्यूमरेशन
परफॉर्म करेंगे ब्राउजर में कि व्हाट टाइप
ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन वी आर गेटिंग फ्रॉम दिस
आईपी एड्रेस पोर्ट नंबर 8 इज ओपन ओके तो
घबरा क्यों रहे हो आप
लोग व्हाट इज द आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ आवर
मशीन दिस इज द आईपी एड्रेस मैं अभी
कंट्रोल प्लस जूम कर देता हूं
इसको यह
रहा कॉपी द आईपी
एड्रेस पेस्ट एंड गो
नाउ यह फ इंफॉर्मेशन हमें देखने को मिल
रही है देखिए
कि यहां पर एक इमेज है इमेज को हम सेव कर
लेंगे फरदर स्टैग एनालिसिस के लिए और टेगो
ग्राफी अभी मैं आपको सिखा नहीं रहा हूं
लेकिन जल्दी एक या दो लैब्स के बाद स्टग
ग्राफी आपको मतलब स्टग एनालिसिस आपको
सिखाऊंगा मैं ओके तो अभी राइट क्लिक ओपन
इन न्यू टैब जैसे हमने लास्ट क्लास में
किया था यहां पर हमें क्या देखने को मिल
रहा है एक न्यू इमेज अगर आपने ध्यान दिया
होगा कि ब्राउजर में इमेजेस डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर क्रूड जेपीजी फाइल देखने को मिल रही
है इट्स
ओके तो आपको पता है जब हमने बेसिक वनटी
स्कैन परफॉर्म किया था तो वहां पर
एचटीटीपी एमेशन के अंदर एक डायरेक्टरी
देखने को मिली थी फॉरवर्ड स्ल इमेजेज तो
यह वही डायरेक्टरी है तो हम सिंपली क्या
करते हैं फाइल को तो सेव कर लेंगे
लो सेव सेव इमेज और इमेज का नाम क्या रख
रहे हैं हम कड जेपीजी सेव हमने सेव कर
लिया इस फाइल को अभी इसको हम क्या करते
हैं बार इमेज डायरेक्टरी पर चलते हैं और
चेक करते हैं यहां पर आपको और क्या देखने
को मिल रहा है यह देखिए नाउ यहां पर ओनली
एक ही फाइल है क्रूड जेपीजी जो यह फाइल है
चलो पैरेंट डायरेक्टरी पर चलते हैं गो बैक
तो हम फिर फिर से यहां पर वेबसाइट के ऊपर
दोबारा आ ग इसका मतलब कि जो इमेजेस
डायरेक्टरी है उसके अंदर कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है अभी हम नेक्स्ट क्या
करते हैं नेक्स्ट चीज हमें क्या चेक करनी
है
बताइए बताइए बताइए
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट थिंग हम क्या करें
बताओ ओके सोर्स कोड रिव्यू करना है ओके
चलो राइट क्लिक व्यू पेज सोर्स कोड तो य
पर आपको कुछ दिखाई दे रहा है बताना सभी
लोग इसको रिव्यू करेंगे एचटीएमएल स्टाइल
ए3 दिस वन स्टाइल ओके क्रूड जेपीजी और
यहां पर भी शायद आपको कुछ खास देखने को
नहीं मिल रहा सोर्स कोड में कुछ देखने को
मिल रहा है नहीं
सोर्स कोड के अंदर भी हमें कुछ खास
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
मिली ओके तो सोर्स कोड रिव्यू किया तो
इसके अंदर कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है
robot.txt फाइल और चेक करते
हैं robot.txt फाइल हम चेक करते हैं
अभी मतलब इस वेबसाइट के ऊपर रोट t एकटी
फाइल भी एजिस्ट नहीं करती इससे रिलेटेड भी
हमारे पास कोई इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है जस्ट
हमें यहां पर एक इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है
नॉट फाउंड ओके अचे
2.4.18 ये इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास पहले से
ही है जब हमने सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
परफॉर्म किया था तो यहां पर भी हमें कोई
खास इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली गो बैक नाउ
व्हाट अबाउट दिस
टेक्स्ट चलो टेक्स्ट को हम पढ़ते हैं
स्पाइक ओके स्पाइक और लुक यू आर फाइनली अप
इट्स ए इट्स इट इज अबाउट टाइम थ्री मोर
मिनट्स एंड यू वर गोइंग आउट विद द गार्बेज
जट नाउ यू टोल्ड स्पाइक हियर यू कैन हैक
एनी कंप्यूटर इन द सिस्टम वी डिड लेट ड डू
इट बट वी नीड हर वर्किंग ऑन समथिंग एल्स
एंड यू आर गेटिंग रियल बोल्ड इन द ट बार
बैक देयर नाउ टेक ए लुक अराउंड एंड सी इफ
यू कैन गेट दैट द रूट सिस्टम एंड डोंट
आस्क एनी क्वेश्चन यू नो यू डोंट नीड द
आंसर टू तो इफ यू आर लकी आई विल इवन मेक
यू सम बेल पेपर्स एंड बीफ ओके तो इट आई एम
इट यू शुड हैव एक्सेस टू द डिवाइस दे आर
टॉकिंग अबाउट ऑन योर कंप्यूटर एडवर्ड इन
विल बी ऑन द मेन डेक इफ यू नीड अस आई तो
मतलब इस टेक्स्ट को पढ़ के आपको एक चीज तो
समझ में आ गई कि टेक्स्ट के अंदर बहुत
सारे यूजर्स नेम है बहुत सारे नाम है ओके
एक चीज समझ में आई
ओके आप क्लास के ला लास्ट में निशा कुमावत
आप क्लास के लास्ट में मुझसे पूछ ले जो भी
आपका डाउट ओके तो एक चीज समझ में आ गई
इसके अंदर बहुत सारी यूजर नेयम है तो अभी
क्या करें नेक्स्ट स्टेप
विल बी अवर नेक्स्ट स्टेप कि ओके यहां पर
टेक्स्ट है और टेक्स्ट के अंदर बहुत सारे
नेम्स है तो क्या करें
हम बताइए बताइए ओनली एक नहीं देखो स्पाइक
है उसके बाद जट है ईडी उसके बाद फिर अगेन
फे एडवर्ड इन दे लॉट्स ऑफ नेम्स तो इन ट
केस व्ट शुड आई डू
वो क्या डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग हम
परफॉर्म करेंगे तो उससे पहले और क्या कर
सकते हैं
हम शुभम
बताइए देखिए हमारे पास यहां पर दो तरीके
हैं आपके पास इस टेक्स को देखकर इस टेक्स
को जब हमने एनालाइज किया हमारे पास दे आर
टू वेज एक तो लाइन बाय लाइन हमने इसको
पढ़ा और आईडिया लगाया और उस यूजर नम को हम
क्या करेंगे मैनुअली क्या करेंगे लक्स
एक्सटी की जो एक सेंट्रलाइज फाइल है जो
हमने फाइंड आउट करी उसमें राइट डाउन कर
देंगे वन बाय वन दूसरा एक और चीज है कि हम
इस प्रोसेस को ऑटोमेटिक करना चाहते हैं आई
वांट ऑटोमेटिक मतलब मैं एक टूल के थ्रू इस
टेक्स से एक वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट करना चाहता
हूं तो कैसे कर सकते
हैं ओके मतलब वन बाय वन मैं क्या करना
अपने इसको नेम्स को एक उस लिस्ट के अंदर
लॉगस डटी एक्सटी फाइल के अंदर ऐड करने के
बजाय आई वांट ऑटो ऑटोमेट दिस प्रोसेस हाउ
शुड आई
डू हाउ शुड आई डू उसके लिए एक टूल होता है
नाम सुना किसी ने अभी कि जब भी कोई भी
वेबसाइट है और वेब पेज से हमें जो टेक्स्ट
है वो टेक्स्ट के बेस पर आगे हम टेक्स्ट
के के अंदर जो वर्ड्स होते हैं उन वर्ड्स
के बेस पर हमें अगर कोई वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट
करनी होती है तो बहुत ही एक बेसिक टूल
होता है जिसका नाम नाम होता है क्रिएट
वर्ड लिस्ट ओके क्रिएट वर्ड लिस्ट उस टूल
का जिक्र करते हैं ये रहा टूल का नाम है
क्यूल टूल ओके इट इज ए कस्टम वर्डलिस्ट
जनरेटर इज ए रूबी प्रोग्राम दैट कॉल्स ए
स्पेसिफिक यूआरएल टू ए डिफाइंड डेप्थ एंड
रिटर्न्स ए लिस्ट ऑफ कीवर्ड्स इस टूल का
यूज करेंगे हम क्या करने के लिए वेबसाइट
के वेब पेज को क्रॉल करके उसके अंदर
अवेलेबल जो भी टेक्स्ट है उनसे एक वर्ड
लिस्ट क्रिएट करने के लिए क्योंकि हमें
यूजर्स नेम और पासवर्ड को फाइंड आउट करना
है तो इसलिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा एक
वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट करनी पड़ेगी खुद से अभी
हम क्या कर सकते हैं कॉमन वर्ड लिस्ट पर
डिफाइंड नहीं रह सकते हमें क्या करना होगा
खुद की एक वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट करनी होगी
फ्रॉम द वेब पेज तो उसके लिए एक बहुत ही
बेसिक टूल होता है जिसका नाम है क्यूल
जिसका नाम है क्यूल क्रिएट वर्डलिस्ट ओके
क्यूल्स कम कम्स प्री इंस्टॉल विद नक् विद
दिस टूल वी कैन इजली कलेक्ट वर्ड्स एंड
फ्रेजस फ्रॉम द टारगेट पेज इट इज ए रोबट
प्रोग्राम दैट कैन क्विकली स्क्रैप द वेब
सर्वर ऑफ एनी वेबसाइट
ओके
ओके तो अभी ये देखिए यह इसकी हेल्प फाइल
है इसके सारे बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस है तो
मैंने एक छोटा सा इसका डेमोंस्ट्रेट है जो
मैंने क्या किया हुआ है कहीं एक आर्टिकल
से एक छोटे से अपने नोट्स में नोट्स बना
के रखे हुए हैं ताकि य टूल्स की वर्किंग
आपको समझ में आ जाए जैसे कि मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं बाय यूजिंग द फॉलोइंग कमांड्स
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं कि एक वर्ड लिस्ट
क्रिएट करना चाहता हूं एक किससे यूआरएल से
तो हम कैसे यूज करेंगे क्यूल एचटीटीपी फुल
आपको पाथ मेंशन करना है एटीटीपी फॉरवर्ड
wwwwe.com या यहां पर हमारा टारगेट आईपी आ
जाएगा तो ये क्या करेगा आपका जो वेब वेब
पेज है वेबसाइट का उसको क्रॉल करेगा और
क्रॉल करके उससे क्या करेगा उन वर्ड्स या
फ्रेजस के बेस पर क्या करेगा एक वर्ड
लिस्ट क्रिएट कर देगा नेक्स्ट अगर मुझे इस
वर्ड लिस्ट को क्या करना चाहता हूं किसी
भी एक टेक्स्ट फाइल के अंदर सेव करना
चाहता हूं तो वो भी मैं कर सकता हूं कैसे
हान डब् ऑप्शन का यूज करके मैं जैसे कि .
t एकटी इस फाइल के अंदर क्या कर सकता हूं
स्टोर कर सकता हूं देन देन उसके बाद उस
वर्ड लिस्ट को हम हैड टेल या कैट कमांड की
हेल्प से देख सकते हैं इफ यू वांट टू
क्रिएट ए वर्ड लिस्ट ऑफ स्पेसिफिक लेंथ
देन यू कैन चूज टू यूज ऑप्शन हान m हान ए
ऑप्शन का हम यूज कर सकते हैं अगर मैं
चाहता हूं कि जो वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट हो उनके
जो वर्ड्स की एक स्पेसिफिक लेंथ हो
क्योंकि अगर
मैंने इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की और ड्यूरिंग
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कोई लॉगइन पेज है तो
उससे मैंने क्या किया एक आईडिया लगाया
वहां पर या हमें एक इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई कि
यह जो कंपनी है एक पासवर्ड पॉलिस यूज कर
रही है उस पासवर्ड पॉलिसी में डिफाइन किया
कि मिनिमम इतनी लेंथ होनी चाहिए और
मैक्सिमम इतनी होनी चाहिए या मैक्सिमम कुछ
भी हो सकती है लेकिन मिनिमम इतनी होनी
चाहिए तो उसके बेस पर मैं अगर मैं चाहता
हूं कि जो वर्ड्स है उसकी लेंथ डिफाइन
करना और उसी लेंथ के बेस पर अपनी वर्ड
लिस्ट क्रिएट करना तो वो भी मैं कर सकता
हूं जैसे कि यहां पर हमने क्या किया हाइन
एम 10 वर्ड्स नंबर ऑफ वर्ड्स कितने होंगे
10 तो सारे के सारे जो नंबर ऑ वर्ड्स
होंगे 10 है उसकी एक लिस्ट क्रिएट कर देगा
देखो सो बेसिकली दिस विल क्रिएट कट वर्ड
लिस्ट इन विच ईच वर्ड हैज ए मिनिमम ऑफ 10
लेटर्स एंड स्टोर दिस कीवर्ड इन
द डिसटी एकटी फाइल डटी एक्सटी फाइल ओके
हान ऑप्शन भी यूज कर सकते हैं इन ऑर्डर टू
रिट्रीव ईमेल्स ओनली अगर मैं वेबसाइट से
ईमेल आईडी को ही रिट्रीव करना चाहता हूं
बाकी वर्ड्स को नहीं तो उस उस केस में हम
यूज करेंगे हाइन ई ऑप्शन विद हान ए ऑप्शन
क्या करता है हाइड द लिस्ट
क्रिएटेड्रॉअर्नेविगेटर
ओके तो आप ऐसे इस तरीके से ओनली वेबसाइट
के अंदर अवेलेबल ईमेल आईडी को भी क्या कर
सकते हो क्रॉल कर सकते हो इफ यू वांट टू
काउंट द नंबर ऑफ टाइम्स ए वर्ड इज रिपीटेड
ऑन ए वेबसाइट देन यूज दफन सी ऑप्शन अगर
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं कि नंबर ऑफ
वर्ड्स ओके वर्ड लिस्ट तो हमने क्रिएट कर
ली लेकिन एक पर्टिकुलर वर्ड कितनी बार
रिपीट हुआ है किसी भी वेबसाइट के अंदर वो
चेक करना चाहता हूं तो इस टूल्स की हेल्प
से हम वो भी चेक कर सकते हैं हान सी उसके
सामने काउंट करके बता लर्न इतनी टाइम्स है
मोर इतनी टाइ है और हाई फन डी ऑप्शन का
मतलब क्या है आप यहां पर डेप्थ डिसाइड कर
सकते हो कि कितनी डेप्थ तक आप क्या करना
चाहते हो क्रॉल करना चाहते हो तो बाय
डिफॉल्ट टू होता है लेकिन आप उससे भी
ज्यादा डेप्थ में जा सकते हैं मतलब अगर उस
वेबसाइट के अंदर लिंक है तो उस लिंक को भी
ये क्रोल करेगा तो यह इस तरीके से इसकी
डेप्थ डिफाइन की जाती है नेक्स्ट हाइ फन व
ऑप्शन भी यूज कर सकते हैं वर्बोस मोड अगर
मैं चेक करना चाहता हूं कि मेरी वेबसाइट
कैसे परफॉर्म कर रही है कॉलिंग या किस
तरीके से वो रिजल्ट फा फाइंड आउट कर रही
है कॉलिंग कॉल्ड रिजल्ट फाइंड आउट कर रही
है तो उस केस में हाइन व वर्बोस ऑप्शन का
भी हम यूज कर सकते हैं देन सम टाइम्स इट
मे हैपन दैट यू मे नीड एन अल्फा न्यूमेरिक
वर्ड लिस्ट अगर मुझे अल्फा न्यूमेरिक वर्ड
लिस्ट चाहिए तो हमें क्या करना होगा हाइन
हाइफ विद नंबर्स मेंशन करना होगा एंड ऑफ
दिस ऑप्शन मतलब केवल आपका टारगेट फुल पाथ
देन उसके बाद हम हाइन हाइन विद नंबर्स तो
ये क्या है अल्फा न्यूमेरिक वर्ड लिस्ट भी
क्रिएट करके दे देगा ये इसका बेसिक यूज
केस था जो आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो क्यूल
टूल को तो हम अपनी अपनी वेबसाइट पर यूज
करते हैं ओके सबको क्लियर है कैसे हम यूज
करते
हैं एवरीवन
क्लियर कि व्ट इज क्यूल टूल एंड हाउ इट
कैन बी यूज्ड बाय एनी पन
टेस्टर
एवरीवन किसी को कोई डाउट है इससे रिलेटेड
कोई मुझसे पूछ सकता है रिलेटेड टू द दिस
टूल कोई डाउट नहीं है किसी
को
क्लियर सबको आता था यह टूल पहले
से सबको आता
था शायद कुछ लोगों के लिए नया होगा अगर
वेब पेज से मुझे एक बेसिक वर्ड लिस्ट
फाइंड आउट करनी है तो रदर देन मैं खुद से
मैनुअली वन बाय वन हम क्या
करें टाइप करने की बजाय क्या कर सकते हैं
मैनुअली भी कर सकते हैं नाउ ओके तो अभी हम
क्या करते हैं फिर से अपने टारगेट पर चलते
हैं और यूज करते हैं नाउ दिस वन नॉट दिस
वन ओके तो कैसे यूज कर सकते इसको हम यह
रहा तो यह बाय डिफॉल्ट अवेलेबल आपका काली
लिस के अंदर क्यूल उसके बाद हाइन
एचटीटीपी फॉरव स्ल कट्र शिट v टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस ओके और देन मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं इसको अपेंड करना चाहता हूं किसके अंदर
लॉक्ड t एकटी के अंदर लॉक्स डटी एकटी के
अंदर तो लॉक्स डटी एकटी फाइल के अंदर तो
हिट
एंटर इट विल टेक्स वेरी लिटिल टाइम एंड
फाइनली इट विल क्रिएट वर्डलिस्ट अगर हम
इसको कैट करते हैं हम और लॉक्स
एकटी हिट एंटर अभी देखिए अभी यहां पर क्या
है कि
अननेसेसरी जो वर्ड जैसे कि यह हो गया यू
एंड द नीड स्पाइक लुक अबाउट व नाउ कैन एनी
क सिस्टम अभी जो कुछ ऐसे वर्ड थे जिनकी
जरूरत नहीं थी उनको भी इसने ऐड कर दिया
क्योंकि इट इज वेरी वेरी बेसिक टूल नॉट
एडवांस टूल
इसलिए यह आपके इन वर्ड को फिल्टर नहीं
करता यह जो अननेसेसरी के जो वर्ड्स होते
हैं उनको हटाता नहीं ओके अगर आपको इनको
रिमूव करना है तो उसके लिए आपको खुद से
कोई स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी होगी लेकिन अभी आपको
कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट लिखने की जरूरत नहीं है
लेकिन इन फ्यूचर अगर आप जैसे जैसे एडवांस
स्टेप परफॉर्म करोगे जब एडवांस में जाओगे
तो आप खुद की वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट करना भी
खुद की स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करना भी सीख
जाओगे और खुद की स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करके आप
क्या कर सकते हो इन जो अननेसेसरी जो
रिक्वायर्ड वर्ड नहीं है उनको क्या कर
सकते हो आप रिमूव कर सकते हो बट अभी के
लिए हमें नहीं चाहिए अभी के लिए हम क्या
कर सकते हैं ली कुछ टूल्स होते हैं जो
ऑटोमेटिक य काम कर लेते हैं और यह चेक कर
लेते हैं तो उन टूल को यूज करेंगे तो अभी
हमारे पास एक कस्टम वर्ड लिस्ट है कैट कि
लड्स कस्टम वर्ड लिस्ट है हम कह सकते कि
इट इज ए कॉमिनेशन ऑफ यूजर्स नेम एंड
पासवर्ड मे बी हमारे पास एक कस्टम वर्ड
लिस्ट नाउ अभी हम क्या
करेंगे अभी हम ब्रूट फोर्स करेंगे एसएसएस
के ऊपर अभी ओके ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करने से
पहले हम क्या करते हैं एक बार डब टूल यूज
करके यह फाइंड आउट करते हैं कौन-कौन सी
डायरेक्टरीज और पेजेस अवेलेबल है हमारे
टारगेट वेबसाइट के ऊपर क्योंकि अचे सर्वर
रनिंग है तो एक बार डरबस्टर का भी यूज कर
लेते हैं
हम पैरेलल में डरबस्टर
ओके लीगल हेल्प अभी मैं आपकी मदद नहीं कर
सकता क्योंकि जब टाइम आएगा तब मैं कर लू ज
यूज करेंगे क अी हमारा आउट ऑफ सिलेबस मत
जाइए आप अभी तो यह मेरा डर बस्ट टूल है
थोड़ा सा इसको खुद से जूम कर लीजिए अभी
अभी इसको मैं कैसे जूम करूंगा एक
मिनट ओके तो अभी इससे जूम नहीं कर पा रहे
हम तो थोड़ा खुद से जूम कर लीजिए
ना तो नाउ ओके
एचटीटीपी उसके बाद सबको यूज करना आता है
शायद सभी को यूज करना आता है कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट ब टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस हमारा टारगेट
आईपी
एड्रेस च इज आवर टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस अपना
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस क्या
हमारा
कॉपी दिस इ आवर टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस
10.10.10 245 य हमारा टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
है ओके बाय डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट एटी है ऑटो
स्विच है नंबर ऑ थ्रेड बाय डिफॉल्ट रहने
देते हैं लिस्ट बेस ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म
करेंगे ब्राउज करते हैं वर्डलिस्ट सिलेक्ट
करते हैं हम कौन सी वर्डली सेलेक्ट करेंगे
अभी
हम की की की डाउनलोड्स के अंदर चले ग
हम गो टू डाउनलोड्स
एंड ये रही डायरेक्टली लिस्ट 2.3 वाली
स्लेक्ट हमने वर्ड लिस्ट किया आप सबको पता
है कि हमें वर्ड लिस्ट कहां से सेलेक्ट
करनी है या आप रैंडम वर्ड लिस्ट खुद की भी
क्रिएट कर सकते हो विद द हेल्प ऑफ क्रंच
या और भी अर टूल्स होते हैं तो अभी के लिए
बाय डिफॉल्ट यह डलिस है जो
डायरेक्टरी जो डर बस्टर के साथ आती है
लेकिन हमारी मशीन में अवेलेबल नहीं होगी
तो हमने इसको ग से डाउनलोड किया था तो
डायरेक्टली स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट करते
हैं तो वी नो द ऑलरेडी इमेजेस आइकन
403 डायरेक्टरी अवेलेबल
है कमांड लाइन कैसे यूज करें व भी करेंगे
मैं देखो एक लैब में सारे टूल्स को यूज
करके नहीं दिखाऊंगा जैसे-जैसे हम क्या
करेंगे कि इन टूल्स के अल्टरनेटिव भी यूज
करेंगे जैसे गो बस्टर भी हम यूज करेंगे
अपकमिंग क्लास में लेकिन मैं फ फैमिलियर
करवाऊंगी आप लोगों को कि ये ये टूल्स
अवेलेबल हैं आप लोग ताकि आसानी से अपनी
चीट शीट क्रिएट कर सके आपको पता चल जाए कि
डरबस्टर भी होता है गो बस्टर भी होता है
अभी नया टूल क्यूल कस्टम वर्डलिस्ट जनरेटर
फ्रॉम द वेब पेजेस उसको स्पाइडरिंग के
थ्रू या क्रॉल करके एक नया टूल आपको पता
चल गया और एक और नया टूल आप अभी ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग के लिए यूज करने वाले हैं तो अभी
टाइम लेगा तो अभी इसको हम क्या करते हैं
अभी चलने देते हैं तो नेक्स्ट हम क्या
परफॉर्म करने हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स
ओके डायरेक्ट ये डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स
हमारा चल रहा है अभी हम क्या काम करने
वाले हैं ये रहा हमारा तो ओके थर्ड टैप
अभी हम क्या करेंगे एसएसए के ऊपर ब्रूट
फोर्स ट्राई करेंगे अभी जब मुझे एसएसएस के
ऊपर अगर ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करना है
क्योंकि एफटीपी से जो इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करनी थी वो हमें मिल गी एचटीटीपी वेब
पेज से जो भी एन्यूमरेशन करना था वो हमने
कर लिया दैट ऑल यह काफी है क्योंकि अभी
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग चल रही है वह
चलती रहेगी उससे हमें आईडिया हो जाएगा
कौन-कौन से वेबसाइट या वेब पेजेस या अदर
डायरेक्टरीज अवेलेबल है रोबोट डटी एक्सटी
फाइल्स में हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिला इमेजेस
जो डायरेक्टरी मिली थी एटीपी नॉमिनेशन के
थ्रू उसके अंदर भी हमें कोई इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं मिली तो अभी हम क्या करेंगे ब्रूट
फोर्स करेंगे एसएसए ब्रूट फोर्स ओके तो
एसएसएस ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म करने के लिए
हम यूज करते हैं एक टूल का नाम है कौन सा
टूल हम यूज करेंगे बताइए एवरीवन
वच टूल व वी यूज फॉर द ब्रूट फोर्स ऑफ
एसएसए एसएसए ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए कौन सा
टूल यूज करने वाले हैं आज आपको मैं नया
टूल
बताऊंगा नहीं हां डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्स के
थ्रू हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिलने वाला यह बात
बिल्कुल सही बोल रहा है यहां पर हमें कुछ
भी नहीं मिलने
वाला तो अभी मैं इसको स्टॉप ही कर देता
हूं वैसे क्योंकि अननेसेसरी हमारी मशीन पर
लोड पड़ेगा और लैब सॉल्व नहीं कर पाएंगे
तो इसको अभी के लिए मैं क्या करता हूं
स्टॉप कर देता हूं यह आपको खुद से परफॉर्म
करना वो सच बोल रहा है क्योंकि डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्स से हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिलने
वाला ओके एमएसएफ कंसोल से भी आप कर सकते
हो दूसरा कोई टूल आप लोगों को याद है जो
हम यूज कर सकते हैं या शुभम हाइड्रा का हम
यूज कर सकते हैं तो सबसे पहले मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन करता हूं कि हाइड्रा क्या है
हाइड्रा को आप कैसे यूज कर सकते हो अब
काफी सिंपल इजी वे आपको बताऊंगा कि कैसे
आप हाइड्रा को यूज कर सकते हो और यह
हाइड्रा टूल होता क्या है और हाइड्रा के
थ्रू आप कैसे एसएसएस नहीं बाकी ब्रूट
फोर्स भी कैसे ट्राई कर सकते हो आप आज
आपके सामने एक और नया टूल हम परफॉर्म करने
वाले हैं हाइड्रा ओके तो यह हमारा हाइड्रा
टूल है तो हाइड्रा क्या है हाइड्रा इज ए
वर्सटाइल पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग टूल कैपेबल ऑफ
लॉन्चिंग ब्रूट फोर्स एंड डिक्शनरी अटैक
अगेंस्ट वेरियस सर्विसेस हाइड्रा इज अ
फास्ट एंड फ्लेक्सिबल पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग
टूल दैट स्पोर्ट्स न्यूमरस प्रोटोकॉल्स
मींस हाइड्रा इज ए सर्विस ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
टूल समझ में आया यह एक सर्विस ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग टूल है इफ यू आर ट्राइट ब्रूट
फोर्स पासवर्ड्स एंड पास फ्रेस ऑफ फाइल
दैट आर
एजिस्टिफाई
टूल का कोई मतलब नहीं है उस केस में यूज
करना ओके दे आर डिफरेंट टूल्स फॉर दैट
सिनेरियो अगर आपकी मशीन है मशीन के अंदर
पासवर्ड अवेलेबल है या हैश अवेलेबल है या
पास फ्रेस अवेलेबल है उस केस में हाइड्रा
टूल का कोई फायदा नहीं यूज करने का यूजलेस
है उस केस में जैसे जोन द रिपर जैसे टूल्स
आपके लिए हेल्पफुल होते हैं उसके लिए और
भी अदर टूल्स होते हैं बट इफ यू वांट टू
ब्रूट फॉर द क्रेडेंशियल ऑफ एफटीपी एसएसए
जैसे कि
एफटीपी
एफटीपी एसएसए आरडी
एचटीटीपी लॉगइन फॉर्म या एसएमबी या कोई
अदर सर्विसेस अगर आप इनको ब्रूट फोर्स
करना चाहते हो इनके अंदर यूजर्स नेम या
पासवर्ड को पता लगाना चाहते हो उस केस में
आप हाइड्रा को यूज कर सकते हो ओके इफ यू
वांट टू ब्रूट फॉर द क्रेडेंशियल एफटीपी
एसएसए आरडीपी एचटीटीपी एसएमबी इन दैट केस
यू कैन यूज हाइड्रा इट सिलिटी मेक इट एन
इंपोर्टेंट एसेट फॉर सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल
टू असेस द स्ट्रेंथ ऑफ पासवर्ड्स एंड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
परफॉर्म ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक बाय सिस्टमिकली
अटेंप्ट डिफरेंट कॉमिनेशन ऑ यूजर्स नेम
एंड पासवर्ड
अंट्सल ओके तो वही है कि हाइड्रा में क्या
कर सकते हो आप वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन करोगे
हाइड्रा को एक वर्ड लिस्ट प्रोवाइड करोगे
हाइड्रा क्या करेगा उस वर्ड लिस्ट को क्या
करेगा उस कॉमिनेशन को ट्राई करेगा और उसके
बेस पर जो करेक्ट क्रेडेंशियल हैं अगर वो
अवेलेबल होंगे उनको फाइंड आउट करके देगा
आपके सामने रिजल्ट में हाइड्रा ज फ्यू
ऑप्शंस उस हाइड्रा के केस में यही ऑप्शन
यूज करते हो आप हाइन स्मल एल हाइन कैपिटल
एल हाइन स्मल प और हाइन कैपिटल प ये चारही
ऑप्शन का यूज किया जाता है हाइड्रा के केस
में और काफी इजी तरीके से मैं आपको बता
दूंगा कि कितने कॉमिनेशन आप यूज कर सकते
हो और हाइन एल स्ल एल हाइन कैपिटल एल हाइ
फनल प और हाइन कैपिटल प का मतलब क्या होता
है और आज के बाद इस चीट शीट को आप क्या कर
सकते हो अभी स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए और अपने
कहीं पर नोट्स में चिपका लीजिए इसको
क्योंकि आपको काफी हेल्प करने वाला है
लाइफ टाइम ओके अगर हान सिंपल एल यूज कर
रहे हो तो यू नो द यूजर नेम बट यू डोंट नो
द पासवर्ड हाइन स्मल एल तब यूज करते हो कि
आपको पता है कि यूजर नेम क्या है लेकिन
आपको पासवर्ड का नहीं पता ओके हाइन कैपिटल
एल का तब यूज करते हो कि आपको नहीं पता कि
यूजर नेम क्या है उस केस में क्या करते हो
आप वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन करते हो अगर आपको
यूजर नेम का नहीं आईडिया और अगर आपको यूजर
नेम के लिए भी वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन करनी है
तो उस केस में आप यूज करोगे हाइन कैपिटल
एल का रदर देन हाइल स्मल एल क्योंकि हाइन
स्मल एल तभी यूज करोगे जब आपके पास यूजर
नेम होगा हाइन स्मल पी का तब आप यूज करोगे
जब आपके पास पासवर्ड होगा लेकिन यूजर नेम
नहीं होगा ओके जरूरी नहीं है आपके पास
यूजर नेम भी हो सकता है और पासवर्ड भी हो
सकता है उस केस में इसका कॉमिनेशन का कोई
फायदा नहीं हाइन कैपिटल पी का तब यूज
करोगे जब आपके पास क्या है एक तो यूजर नेम
है पासवर्ड नहीं है तो यहां पर पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड वर्डलिस्ट मेंशन करते हो या आपके
पास यूजर नेम है और आपके पास पासवर्ड नहीं
है तो उस केस में क्या करते हो फिर भी आप
क्या कर सकते हो पासवर्ड का पासवर्ड लिस्ट
यहां पर प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो जैसे कि
पॉसिबल कॉमिनेशन क्या हो सकते हो जो हाडर
के साथ यूज कर सकते हो हाइन स्मल एल
कैपिटल पी मतलब यूजर नेम है और पासवर्ड
वर्डलिस्ट आप मेंशन करो दिस इ द फर्स्ट
कॉमिनेशन सेकंड कॉमिनेशन क्या हो सकता है
हाइन कैपिटल एल मतलब वर्ड यूजर के लिए भी
आप वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन कर रहे हो पासवर्ड के
लिए भी आप वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन कर रहे हो दिस
इज अ कॉमिनेशन
टू कैपिटल एल और स्मल प आप यूज कर सकते हो
मतलब आपके पास यूजर नेम नहीं है तो आप
यूजर नेम के लिए वर्डलिस्ट यूज कर सकते हो
और आपको पासवर्ड पता है तो यह है आपका
कॉमिनेशन थ्री कैपिटल एल और स्मल प स्मल
एल और स्मल प का भी कॉमिनेशन नंबर फोर बट
इट इज यूजलेस जब आपके पास यूज नेम भी और
पासवर्ड है तो आपको ब्रुड फोर्स करने की
जरूरत ही नहीं तो इसलिए हमारे लिए क्या
यूजफुल है तो तीन ही कॉमिनेशन हमारे लिए
यूजफुल है अगर आपके पास यूजर नेम है
पासवर्ड नहीं है तो पासवर्ड वर्डलिस्ट आप
मेंशन करते हो सेकंड कॉमिनेशन क्या है अगर
आपके पास दोनों ही नहीं है तो दोनों
वर्डलिस्ट मेंशन करते हो थर्ड कॉमिनेशन
क्या आपके पास यूजर नेम नहीं है पासवर्ड
है तो कॉमिनेशन थ्री आप यूज कर सकते हो इन
केस ऑफ हाइड्रा एवरीवन क्लियर हाउ वी यूज
हाइड्रा
एवरीवन क्लियर सभी
बताइए अभी वर्डलिस्ट तो भाई आप कोई भी यूज
कर सकते हो लेकिन वर्डलिस्ट वैलिड होनी
चाहिए आज हमारे पास वर्ड लिस है तो
हाइड्रा सबको यूज करना आ
गया जब भी कोई आपको बोलेगा कि भाई हाइड्रा
टूल से ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करना
है तो आप कर
लोगे और हाइड्रा को कहां पर यूज करना है
यह भी पता चल
गया बताइए
एवरीवन सबको पता चल गया कि हाइड्रा को
कहां पर यूज करना है ओनली हाइड्रा को हम
सर्विसेस के केस में ही यूज करते हैं अगर
सिस्टम्स के ऊपर कोई भी क्रेडेंशियल या
कोई भी पास फेसेस या पासवर्ड अवेलेबल है
या बोल सकते हो हैश अवेलेबल उस केस में आप
कभी भी हाइड्रा का यूज नहीं करते
ओके
ओके चलो अभी हम इसको यूज करते हैं ब्रूट
फोर्स ट्राई करते हैं हम किसके ऊपर
अपने अपने एसएसएस के ऊपर तो कैसे करेंगे
देखो
हाइड्रा हाइड्रा हाइन कैपिटल एल क्योंकि
हमारे पास ना तो पासवर्ड है और ना ही
हमारे पास यूजर नेम है ओके तो कैपिटल एल
और उसके बाद कौन सी फाइल यूज करने वाले
हैं हम log.txt
कैपिटल
एल log.txt क्योंकि यही वर्ड लिस्ट है जो
हमने
एफटीपी सर्वर से कलेक्ट की है या जो वेब
वेब पेज को क्रॉल करके एक वर्ड लिस्ट बनाई
थी या एक टास्क t एकटी फाइल से सबको हमने
क्या किया एक फाइल के अंदर सेव कर लिया
यही हमारी वर्डलिस्ट फाइल है
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद हान कैपिटल
p log.txt देन
उसके बाद मैं क्या कर टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस देन आपको डिफाइन करना
है किस टाइप की सर्विस के लिए आप रूट
फोर्स ट्राई कर रहे हो तो एसएस एच ओके एक
तो ऐसे परफॉर्म कर सकते हो या आप एसएसए और
एक दूसरा तरीका है तो
आप नहीं पाथ देने की जरूरत नहीं है
क्योंकि आपकी वर्ड लिस्ट ऑलरेडी यहीं पर
अवेलेबल है अगर आपको नहीं पता तो मैं आपको
एक काम कर देता हूं दिखा दूंगा यरी जो
लिस्ट है जो डायरेक्टरी है इसी के अंदर
अवेलेबल सबको पता है
ना तो हिट एंटर यह रहा इट विल टेक टाइम
क्योंकि यह ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई कर रहा है
और उसके बाद आपको करेक्ट यूजर नेम एंड
पासवर्ड बता
देगा तो अभी ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई कर रहा है
हमारे एसएसए सर्विस के
ऊपर यहां तक सबको समझ में आया लैब सॉल्व
करते हैं टेक्निक सबको पता चल रही है कि
स्टेप बाय स्टेप कैसे आगे बढ़ते हैं हम कि
जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती रहेगी उसको राइट डाउन
करना है किसी भी फाइल के अंदर या जहां पर
हमें रिफरेंस लेना है हर एक इंफॉर्मेशन को
राइट डाउन करना है नोट डाउन करना है और
कैसे स्टेप बाय स्टेप हमें आगे बढ़ना है
एवरीवन क्लियर
यार यस नो हां तो बता दिया करो दे ओनली टू
और थ्री स्टूडेंट दो कंटीन्यूअसली मेरे हर
क्वेश्चन का आंसर करते
हैं इट विल टेक टाइम टाइम टाइम टाइम
क्योंकि यह आपकी ब्रूट फोर्स है ब्रूट
फोर्स हमेशा टाइम लेता है
तब तक किसी का कोई डाउट है मुझसे पूछ सकता
है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास नॉट आउट ऑफ
सिलेबस क्योंकि जब तक हमें एसएसएस के
क्रेडेंशियल नहीं मिल सकते मिले तब तक हम
कुछ भी नहीं कर सकते
हैं और आप लोगों के लिए एक टास्क रहेगा आज
आप लोगों को एक लैब सॉल्व करनी है काफी
बेसिक लैब है सिमिलर टू दो जो लैब हमने की
है ना बुकली एक तो यह है कौन सी
हमने पहली लैब जो सीटीएफ परफॉर्म वन किया
था और दूसरा यह बाउंट हैकर बिल्कुल इन
दोनों का कॉमिनेशन यूज करोगे तो उस ले लैब
को आप काफी इजली सॉल्व कर लोगे वो लैब
आपकी जो डिपेंड करती है दो तरीके से सॉल्व
हो सकती है एक तो जो मैंने पढ़ाया अभी तक
वोह और एक दूसरा जो तरीका है जो स्टैक
एनालिसिस है वाला है वह मैंने आपको पढ़ाया
नहीं है तो उस तरीके से आपको सॉल्व नहीं
करना है ओके वक थ्रो की हेल्प नहीं लेनी
है किसी की हेल्प नहीं लेनी है खुद से
ट्राई करना है कहीं पर स्टक हो रहे हो तो
मुझसे पूछना है किसमें कमेंट सेक्शन में
और नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम क्या करेंगे उस
लैब को सबसे पहले सॉल्व करेंगे जल्दी से
सीटीएफ को फाइंड आउट करेंगे उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट लैब ट्राई करेंगे तब तक के लिए
आपको क्या करना है उस लैब को ट्राई करना
है फ्लैग सबमिट करना है उसके बाद लिंकडन
पेज प जाकर आपको टैग करके रिपोर्ट बनानी
है सभी को उस लैब का नाम रहेगा आपका
क्योंकि दो तरीकों से व लैब सॉल्व हो सकती
है दो टेक्निक्स है और हमेशा एक काम किया
करो आप लोग कि मेरी जो टेक्निक्स है उसको
कॉपी करने की जरूरत नहीं है आप खुद की
टेक्निक खुद की अप्रोच बनाइए और खुद की
अप्रोच से उसको सॉल्व करने की कोशिश कीजिए
किसी भी लैब को ओके और एक लैब को एक तरीके
से
नहीं मल्टीपल तरीकों से सॉल्व करने की
कोशिश करें ओनली एक तरीके पर डिपेंडेंट ना
रहे ओके लैब लिंक मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
जस्ट सेकंड ऑलरेडी हमारी एक लैब चल रही है
तो क्लास के एंड में मैं आपको बता दूंगा
उसके लिए आपको रुकना
पड़ेगा अभी थोड़ा सा देखते हैं
कि ओहो यह तो वैसे ही
है 862
ट्राइज इट विल टेक
टाइम हमें वेट करना
होगा रिवीजन किसका चाहिए
म ूल आपकी सिचुएशन पर डिपेंड करता
है नहीं आप स्टैंडर्ड वे है देखिए मैंने
आपको एक लैब दी है फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने एक
टारगेट दिया यह रहा बाउंट हैकर कि आप
लोगों को बाउंट हैकर पर पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग करनी है उसके अंदर ती फ्लैग अभी
तो जैसे कि बाउंट आकन के अंदर ज्यादा
फ्लैग्स है तो उसको आप सॉल्व करोगे और
सॉल्व करके स्क्रीनशॉट के साथ क्योंकि
आपकी यूजर आईडी रहेगी और कौन-कौन से स्टेप
आपने फॉलो किए कि स्टेप नंबर वन में आपने
क्या किया क्या इंफॉर्मेशन मिली और उस
इंफॉर्मेशन पर आपने क्या किया स्टेप नंबर
टू क्या किया कि वो इंफॉर्मेशन आपने
एन्यूमरेशन किया एन्यूमरेशन में ये
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली स्टेप नंबर थ्री ओके फर्द
क्या चीज की जैसे हमने एफटीपी को एफटीपी
को एनोनिमस लॉग इन किया वहां से हमें दो
फाइल मिली स्टेप नंबर फोर उस फाइल को हमने
एनालाइज किया उसके बाद उसको एज ए
वर्डलिस्ट हम यूज कर रहे हैं और तभी साथ
के साथ स्टेप नंबर फोर या बोल सकते हो हम
पोर्ट नंबर 80 को भी क्या किया डायरेक्टली
बूट फोर्स किया कुछ नहीं मिला robot.txt
फाइल से हमें कुछ नहीं मिला हमें जो
टेक्स्ट था टेक्स्ट से हमने क्या किया एक
वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट की एक एक वर्डलिस्ट
क्रिएट करके हमने क्या किया जो log.txt थी
जो वर्डलिस्ट हमें कहां से मिली
थी जो वर्डलिस्ट
हमें कहां से मिली थी एफटीपी सर्वर से
उनको कंबाइन ली एक वर्ड लिस्ट बनाया उसके
बाद हमने एसएसएस ब्रूट फोर्स किया एसस
ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहे हैं वहां से हमें
क्रेडेंशियल मिलेंगे जब हमें क्रेडेंशियल
मिलेंगे हम उनको यूज करेंगे तो इस तरीके
से आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप बताना है कि आपने
क्या टेक्निक का यूज किया और फ्लैग को
सबमिट
किया हां आप मीडियम पे भी अपलोड कर सकते
हो या आप लोग
कुछ करते थे तो आपको काफी पॉजिटिव हेल्प
करेगा नॉट नेगेटिव पॉजिटिव वे में हेल्प
करेगा दूसरा जब भी आप कोई आर्टिकल लिखोगे
तो आर्टिकल में क्या स्क्रीनशॉट है प्लस
में आपको कुछ एक्सप्लेनेशन देनी होगी अब
जब आप किसी चीज की एक्सप्लेनेशन प्रोवाइड
करोगे तो उसके लिए आपको रिसर्च करनी होगी
इससे आपका खुद की नॉलेज एनहांस होगी
नहीं सुडो के साथ स्टार्ट करने की जरूरत
नहीं है इसके अंदर क्रेडेंशियल है मैं
आपको मेरे पास है व क्रेडेंशियल
वैसे उतना ही टाइम लेगा यह डोंट वरी
अगर आप लोग बोल रहे हो सुडो के स्टार्ट
साथ स्टार्ट कीजिए
ओके तो मुझे
अभी पूरी मेहनत वेस्ट हो
जाएगी फाइल लाज मुझे पता है
चलो आप लोगों के लिए थोड़ा फास्ट वे कर
देता हूं
इसमें हमें हम एक काम करते इसको थोड़ा सा
फास्ट वे कर देते हैं ब मैं थोड़ा सा ननो
की हेल्प से लड्स फाइल उसको थोड़ा सा
मॉडिफाई करता हूं कैसे क्योंकि इसमें जो
यूज नेम है इन्हीं के अंदर है यह रहा अभी
इनको हम क्या करते कंट्रोल एक्स ओ सॉरी
सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी यह रहा और इनको हम क्या
करेंगे यह
रहा और इनको हम क्या करते य
र कॉपी और सबसे पहले लगाते हैं इनको सबसे
पहले हिट एंटर यह
रहा पेस्ट क्लिप बोर्ड डिलीट यह रहा अभी
हम ऐसे ट्राई करते हैं इसको तो आपको पता
चल जाएगा यह
रहा एक
किए अभी भी मैंने नहीं किया क्योंकि थोड़ी
सी गड़बड़ हो गई
थी लो क्योंकि थोड़ा सा फास्ट हो जाएगा
इससे और कुछ नहीं होगा थोड़ा सा फास्ट हो
जाएगा
कंट्रोल
एक्स
यस हिट एंटर ओके फिर से एक बार कैट करते
हैं हम
इसको यस यस यस ओके अभी के लिए हम क्या
करें इसको अभी क्लियर अब करते हैं हम
जो लोग बोल रहे हाइड्रा के साथ सुडो
हाइड्रा हाइन कैपिटल एल लक्ड एक्सटी उसके
बाद हाइन
प लक्स ड एक्सटी उसके बाद टारगेट हमारा
आईपी एड्रेस रहेगा दिस
वन दिस इज आवर टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
और
एसएसए हिट
एंटर इस पर कोई भी फायर वाल आईपी है ही
नहीं ब्लॉक कैसे करेगा अदर वाइज ब्लॉक
करेंगे ब्रूट फोर्स को भी
हां टाइम सेव हो जाएगा पासवर्ड भी मुझे
मालूम है
वैसे शायद अभी जल्दी हो जाएगा
ब्लॉक वाइपर अगर आपको कोई भी फायर वाल इड
करनी है उसके लिए जल्दी अनाउंसमेंट हो
जाएगी एक काफी प्रोफेशनल कोर्स लच होगा
पेड कोर्स होगा वह आप जवाइन कीजिए और कोई
भी आप एटी वायस बायपास करना सीख जाओगे उधर
से
अचे टू का भी नंबर आएगा सभी का नंबर आएगा
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट आईस का भी नंबर आएगा पाचे टू
का भी नंबर आएगा उसके बाद बहुत सारी चीजों
का टन आएगा आपको चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं
है
अगर आप पर्टिकुलर अपने हिसाब से आ रहे हो
तो कोई इशू नहीं है मैं भी अपने हिसाब से
पढ़ाऊंगा
आप स्टूडेंट हो आप अपनी मर्जी से क्लास
टेंड कर सकते हो आपके
पास लिबर्टी है कि आप क्या कर सकते हो कि
नहीं मुझे जो टॉपिक करना है उसी से
रिलेटेड मैं क्लास में अटेंड करूंगा मुझे
और इंटरेस्ट ही नहीं है तो मैं भी एक
टीचर्स हूं आप लोगों के बीच से निकला हूं
तो मैं भी अपने तरीके से ही पढ़ाऊंगा
क्योंकि मेरे पास एक पाथ है एक रोड मैप है
एक सिलेबस है मैं इसको एज ए पेड क्लास
लेकर चल रहा हूं हूं जैसे एक प्लेड पेड
क्लास में मैं पढ़ाता हूं स्टेप बाय स्टेप
वैसे ही मैं इस क्लास को पढ़ाऊंगा क्योंकि
मुझे एक स्टूडेंट को नहीं देखना मुझे पूरे
इंडिया के सभी स्टूडेंट्स को देखना
है वर्डप्रेस का भी नंबर
आएगा देखिए एक काम करते हैं हमारे पास
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड्स हैं वैसे ये ब्रूट
फोर्स ट्राई करेगा तो तब तक हम क्या करते
हैं एक्सेस करते हैं और स्लैब को सॉल्व
करते हैं क्योंकि बहुत ही बेसिक लैब है
इसमें अननेसेसरी टाइम वेस्ट करना हमारे
लिए सही नहीं रहेगा आप लोगों को हाइड्रा
के थ्रू क्या करना है उसको ब्रूट फोर्स
ट्राई करना है और सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन करना
है तो क्या हम यूजरनेम पासवर्ड से ट्राई
करें
एवरीवन ट्राई करें क्योंकि वो यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड इस वर्ड लिस्ट के अंदर है तो उसे
हम एसएसएस के थ्रू एंटर करते हैं
बताओ इट विल टेक टाइम तब तक हम क्या करते
हैं इसको यूज कर लेते
हैं ओके तो अभी हम इसको चलने देते हैं और
जैसे यूजरनेम पासवर्ड आपके सामने आएंगे तो
आपको पता भी चल
जाएगा इसका है यूजर नेम एंड पा एक बार हम
क्रॉस चेक करते कैट लड एक्सटी और इसका य
नेम लिन है और पासवर्ड इसका जो है आप
देखोगे तो पासवर्ड इसका है दिस
वन यह इसका पासवर्ड
है यह इसका पासवर्ड है और यह इसका यूजर
नेम है अब यह कॉमिनेशन ट्राई कर रहा है तो
इट विल टेक टाइम तो चलने देते उसको तो अभी
हम क्या करते हैं एसस के थ्रू मशीन में
लॉग इन करते हैं तो एसएसए और एस के थ्रू
किसी भी मशीन के अंदर रिमोट एक्सेस लेना
है तो कैसे कर सकते एसएसए देन यूजर नेम
लिन रेट टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस हमारा क्या रहेगा
10.10
13245 10 10130
245 10 डट
10130 245 और हिट एंटर कर
देना ओके यस
हिट एंटर पासवर्ड कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व पासवर्ड
हमने एंटर कर दिया ओके परमिशन डिनाइड तो
हमें पासवर्ड को ट्राई करना होगा
पेस्ट ओके आई डू सम मिस्टेक मे
बी दिस इज द पासवर्ड
किसी का आईपी कैसे पता
करें यह तो आप लोग मुझे बताइए फिर
अभी कैसे पता कर सकते हैं
हम एक काम करते हैं फिर से इसको ट्राई
करते लिन है ना
हमारा
13045 इस पर चल रहा अभी वैसे बीजी चल रहा
है इसको हम क्या करते हैं अभी स्टॉप कर
देते हैं क्योंकि फालतू में हमारा टाइम
वेस्ट हो रहा है इससे 10 10 130
ओके हिट एंटर उस पे ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई कर
चल रहा था तो लिन पासवर्ड हमारा कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट
व ओके पासवर्ड हमारा भाई हमें एक काम करना
पड़ेगा टर्मिनल को साइड में ओपन करना
पड़ेगा और तभी इसी के बेस पर हम ट्राई कर
सकते हैं
अरे
[संगीत]
यार ना
मे बी पासवर्ड इ
डिफरेंट हां दिस इज द
पासवर्ड मैं भी यही ट्राई कर रहा
हूं कॉपी
ना ओके एक काम करते हैं हम
हमें इसको ब्रूट फोर्स करना ही पड़ेगा
अभी यस हम इसको क्या करते हैं कंट्रोल सी
और अभी के लिए हम ट्राई करते हैं फिर से
इसको ओनली यूजर नेम तो है ही हमारे पास
करेक्ट आप लोगों ने बोला इसको लिए अभी हम
क्या कर देते हैं फिर से
लेन चलो देखते हैं इसका पासवर्ड क्या है
यह
रहा लिन और यह सेम पासवर्ड है दि
पासवर्ड वन कैट हम क्या ट्राई कर रहे थे य
भी गलत ट्राई कर रहे क्या
हम दि कॉपी एंड एसएसए
लिन @
[संगीत]
10.10.10
245 यस वी सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन हमने
सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन कर लिया यह रहा देखो
एसएसएस के थ्रू लिन बाउंट हैकर डेस्कटॉप
यह रहा अभी हम चेक करें एलएस एलएस परफॉर्म
करने की बज हु एम आई हु एम आई यह देखिए
आईम लिन ओके उसके बाद प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टर मेरी क्या है होम लिन डेस्कटॉप
उसके बाद एलस परफॉर्म करते हैं तो य पर
हमें क्या पला मिला यूजर डटी एक्सटी हमें
एक फ्लैग मिला यहां पर यूजर डटी एक्सटी
इसको कैट और यूजर डॉट टी
एक्सटी यह हमारे पास एक फ्लैग मिल गया
यूजर डटी एक्सटी वाला ट्राई हैक मी
नाउ कॉपी सिलेक्शन एंड गो टू दिस वन व्हाट
इज द यूजर डटी
एक्सटी पेस्ट सबमिट एक फ्लैग मिल गया हमें
रोट डटी एक्सटी हमें फाइंड आउट करना है
व्हाट इज द यूजर पासवर्ड यह भी हम बता
देते हैं अभी इनको एक बार यूजर पासवर्ड भी
हम बता देते हैं तो वन बाय वन हम परफॉर्म
करते हैं दिस इ द यूजर पासवर्ड
देखो कॉपी
सिलेक्शन दिस इज द यूजर
पासवर्ड पेस्ट
सबमिट कौन सी सर्विस हमने ब्रूट फोर्स की
एसएसए करेक्ट आंसर हु रोट द टास्क लिस्ट
टास्क लिस्ट लिन क्योंकि लिन टास्क डॉट
लिस्ट हमने पढ़ा था कैट आउट किया था तो
वहां पर लास्ट में लिन लिखा हुआ था लिन
ओके फाइंड ओपन ओपन पोर्ट्स हमने फाइंड आउट
कर लिया दिस वन इज कंप्लीट ओके करेक्ट
ओनली वन आंसर इज दैट जो हमें फाइंड आउट
करना है रूट रूट फ्लैग को तो हम कैसे
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं अभी हमारे
पास यूजर एक्सेस है कौन सा अभी इसके बाद
हम सीडी देन उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
सीडी रूट में चलते हैं हिट
एंटर सीडी रूट और एल
एस ये रहा सीडी रूट एल एस प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी क्या है मेरी
पीडब्ल्यूडी यह रहा रूट में बट यहां पर
कुछ भी हमें देखने को नहीं मिल रहा सीडी
होम
अभी क्या करते सीडी स्ल रूट हम ट्राई करते
हैं परमिशन डिनाइड वी आर नॉट ऑथराइज बिकॉज
वी आर अनप्रिविलेज्ड अभी यहां पर देखिए एक
चीज बताइए कि हमने एक्सप्लोइटेशन कर लिया
इनिशियल एक्सेस गेट इन कर लिया मशीन के
अंदर अभी हमारा जो फेज स्टार्ट हो गया
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन सबको याद है कि पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन में कितने फेजस है कितने
स्टेजेस है बताना
सभी को पता है कि पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन में
कितने स्टेज
है किसी को भी पता
है यहां पर जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं सभी
स्टूडेंट्स में से किसी को भी पता है कि
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन में कितने फेजेस
हैं तो आपको पोस्ट एक्सटशन फेज पढ़ना
चाहिए जहां पर मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन किया
था सिस्टम हैकिंग की सबसे पहली क्लास में
कि एक्सप्लोइटेशन क्या होता है
एक्सप्लोइटेशन में हम क्या-क्या करने वाले
हैं पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन क्या होता है
उसकी कितनी स्टेजेस होती है उन स्टेजेस को
हम उस स्टेजेस में हम क्या-क्या पढ़ने
वाले हैं तो ये अभी आपका पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन स्टार्ट हो गया है अभी
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन में सबसे पहला आपका
काम होता है आपका लोकल एन्यूमरेशन चाहे वो
विंडोज हो चाहे वो
तो मैं आपको जब भी हम एक्सप्लोइटेशन
परफॉर्म कर लेंगे सक्सेसफुली देन मैं आपको
परफॉर्म करके दिखाऊंगा लोकल एमरे जिसको हम
बोल सकते हैं सिस्टम एमेशन भी बोल सकते
हैं कि यह पता करने की कोशिश करते हैं कि
सिस्टम के ऊपर क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल है तो नक् का लोकल एन्यूमरेशन के
अंदर क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन हमें फाइंड आउट
करनी चाहिए कौन-कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे
लिए इंपोर्टेंट होती है और वह हम कैसे
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं वह हम नेक्स्ट
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में सीखेंगे देन उसके बाद
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन फिर उसके बाद मैंने
आपको बताया था अगर सेल को अपग्रेड करना या
कोई फाइल ट्रांसफर करनी हो तो अभी तक हमें
कोई भी जरूरत नहीं पड़ी है किसी भी फाइल
को ट्रांसफर करने की लेकिन अभी हम वी आर
अनप्रिविलेज्ड यूजर तो नेक्स्ट स्टेप क्या
रहता था आपका फोर्थ स्टेप क्या था आपका
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन तो यहां पर हमें क्या
करना है एक फ्लैग फाइंड आउट करना है जिसका
नाम जिसका रहेगा रूट के अंदर रूट की होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर एक फ्लैग है जिसको
हमें क्या करना है फाइंड आउट करना है तो
उसके लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा रूट यूजर
बनना पड़ेगा अगर हमें रूट यूजर बनना है तो
हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करना पड़े तो प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन इज द स्टेप ऑफ पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन तो अभी हमें प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करने के लिए हमें कुछ अभी इसको
क्या करना पड़ेगा एक्सप्लोइट करना पड़ेगा
फर्द एक्सप्लोइट करना पड़ेगा एवरीवन
क्लियर परसिस्टेंट की हमें अभी जरूरत नहीं
है अभी हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन तो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन में
मुझे अभी अपने पता होना चाहिए कि जो करंट
यूजर्स है करंट यूजर के पास कौन-कौन से
परमिशन है वो एज ए रूट एक रूट के रूप में
या एक एडमिन के रूप में कौन-कौन से काम या
कौन-कौन से टास्क परफॉर्म कर सकता है ओके
तो यहां पर किसी को याद आ रहा है कि हम
प्रिविलेज लिनक्स प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
कैसे ट्राई कर सकते हैं अभी मैं इस मशीन
को एक्सप्लोइट कैसे करूं कि मुझे रूट
एक्सेस मिल जाए किसी को याद है यहां पर
कोई भी बता सकता है अगर मैं इसको सूडो
एलएस करता हूं और उसके बाद रूट जो लास्ट
क्लास में हमने किया था तब भी हमारे पास
क्या है अभी शड ट्राई करेंगे तो हमारे पास
पासवर्ड होगा और ये पासवर्ड हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा यहां से लेना पड़ेगा अभी ओके
यहीं से पासवर्ड हमें लेना पड़ेगा यह
रहा
कॉपी कंट्रोल शिफ्ट v हिट एंटर ओके सॉरी
यूजर लिन इज नॉट अलाउ टू एग्जीक्यूट स्
बिन एल स् रूट एज ए रूट ऑन बाउंट हैकर
मतलब आपको परमिश नहीं है तो मुझे सबसे
पहले यह चेक करना होगा कि जो मैं करंट
यूजर्स हूं मेरे पास कौन-कौन सी परमिश हैं
तो उसके लिए हम यूज करते हैं सूडो हाइन एल
कमांड का यूज करते हैं यह देखिए अभी फिर
से कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व और हिट एंटर तो अभी जो
करंट यूजर लिन है उसके पास कौन-कौन से
प्रिविलेजेस है वह ओनली एक ही बाइनरी फाइल
है जिसको जिसका नाम है टार उसको एज ए रूट
यूजर रन कर सकता है उसको एज ए रूट यूजर रन
कर सकता है इसके अलावा इस मशीन के ऊपर अगर
उसको कोई भी एडमिन लेवल के टास्क परफॉर्म
करने हैं तो व परफॉर्म नहीं कर सकता अदर
देन टार तो मतलब अभी हमें क्या करना होगा
आपको क्या लगता है कि हमें क्या करना होगा
देखो सुडो हान l की अपने कहानी है
इसकी एक अपनी कहानी है अगर आप लोगों का उस
कहानी में इंटरेस्ट है तो एक दिन उस कहानी
को मैं एक्सप्लेन कर दूंगा कि सु न l की
स्टोरी क्या है कि मुझे कैसे पता चलता है
सड आफ हेल ऐसा कैसे हमें बता पाता है कि
इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर को ये कौन-कौन सी परमिश
हैं अगर किसी ने
तो अभी हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा एज ए रूट
यूजर में इसको ओनली टार जो बाइनरी फाइल है
तो सबसे पहले मेरा एक और सवाल है व्हाट इज
द यूज केस ऑफ द व्ट इ द अभी मेरा एक सवाल
था आप लोगों से पूछना चाह रहा था
कि व्हाट इज द सिग्निफिकेंट ऑफ द बिन
डायरेक्टरी एवरीवन नो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करके आप कर सकते हो को
हैक बताइए तो मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा इसका
एक एक्सप्लोर ढूंढना पड़ेगा इसका
एक्सप्लोर ढूंढने के लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा
एक वेबसाइट है ठीक है मुझे वहां पर जाना
पड़ेगा जीटीएफ ऑफ विन एक वेबसाइट है जिसका
नाम
है जीटी एफो बिन ओके यह रही तो इसको हम
जूम करते हैं यहां पर
आपके लिनक्स एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल है
रिलेटेड टू योर बाइनरी फाइल्स यह रहा यहां
पर अगर आप सच पूछोगे तो मुझे भी जितने भी
एक्सप्लोइट है जीटीएफ ऑ बिनस के अंदर मुझे
भी नहीं पता होगा कितने एक्सप्लोइट्स है
कैसे व स्टेप बाय स्टेप काम करते हैं क्या
उनका वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल है इवन मैं ही
नहीं कोई भी प इनको याद नहीं रख सकता बस
हां इसको एज ए चीट शीट का हम पार्ट बनाकर
रख सकते हैं कि अगर मुझे इन फ्यूचर कभी भी
अपनी सिस्टम मशीन के अंदर या अपने टारगेट
मशीन के अंदर अगर मुझे कोई भी बाइनरी फाइल
मिलती है तो उससे रिलेटेड अगर मुझे
एक्सप्लो फाइंड आउट करने है किसके ऊपर
लिनक्स के ऊपर तो मैं वह कहां से देख सकता
हूं अ सच पूछोगे तो मुझे नहीं पता कि कार
का एक्सप्लो जो मिलेगा उसका ये एक्सट काम
कैसे करता है क्योंकि उसे कोई भी याद नहीं
कर सकते कितना बड़ा पेंटेस्ट हो उसको भी
याद नहीं होंगे बस हर कोई रेफरेंस लेता है
बाद में उसको समझने की कोशिश करता है तो
अभी मुझे मेरे पास कौन सी कमांड है आप इस
फाइल का रेफरेंस ले सकते हो
आपको कौन से चाहिए आपको सूडो लेवल के
प्रिविलेजेस चाहिए तो कैसे ले सकते हैं हम
क्लिक ऑन देखो यह रहा तो सूडो से रिलेटेड
य रहा यह सारे एक्सप्लोइट है रिलेटेड टू
योर टार जो टार कमांड है जो बाइनरी फाइल
है उससे रिलेटेड य सारे के सारे
एक्सप्लोइट है और अभी मुझे क्या करना सो
इफ द बाइनरी इ अलाउड टू रन एज सुपर यूरी
बाय सुडो इट डज नॉट ड्रॉप द एलिवेटेड
प्रिविलेजेस एंड मे बी यूज टू एक्सेस द
फाइल सिस्टम एस्केलेट और मेंटेन प्रिविलेज
एक्सेस तो सिंपली क्या करता हूं
सुडो इसको कॉपी करता हूं कॉपी एंड गो टू
माय सेल उसके बाद यहां पर हम क्या कर देते
हैं पेस्ट कर देते हैं सिंपली पेस्ट और
एंटर और नाउ वी
सक्सेसफुली गोट रूट यूजर हमने सक्सेसफुली
चेक करना चाहते हो हु एम आई ये रहा स्टार
रूट यूजर्स हूं मैं अगर मैं एलस करता हूं
तो मेरा फ्लैग यहीं पर होगा बिन ओके एलएस
है इसके अंदर होम डायरेक्टर अंदर चलते हैं
हम तो सीडी और होम देखिए सीडी और होम चेक
करते हैं उसके बाद
एलएस लिन
ओके तो हमें इसके अंदर फ्लैग मिलेगा हमें
कहां पर रूट की होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर तो
सीडी होम उसके बाद लिन है क्लियर एक मिनट
हम इसको क्लियर करते हैं हिट एंटर उसके
बाद पीडब्ल्यूडी प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टर मेरी होम है देन मैं सीडी और
रूट के अंदर चलता हूं डायरेक्टली ये रहा
एल एस या रूट डटी एक्सटी है अगर सूडो हाइ
फनल यहां पर भी मैं परफॉर्म करता हूं तो
आपको पता चला मेरे पास क्या प्रिविलेजेस
है मेरे पास सारे प्रिविलेजेस है ओके ऑल ल
ऑल मैं सिस्टम के साथ कुछ भी कर सकता हूं
तो अभी हमने लेस किया था तो रड एक्सटी कैट
रड t एक्टी
डॉट t एकटी एंड वी सक्सेसफुली एक्सप्लोइट
आवर मशीन तो हमने क्या किया एसएसए ब्रूट
फोर्स किया उसके बाद हमने एक एक्सप्लोइट
सेल एक्सेस लिया और सेल एक्सेस के थ्रू
हमें पता चला जो नॉर्मल यूजर था उसको एक
परमिशन ग्रांट थी एडमिन लेवल की किसकी एक
बाइनरी फाइल के ऊपर टार फाइल केलो हमने
टार से रिलेटेड जो फाइल थी उसका एक
एक्सप्लो फाइंड आउट किया
हमने सक्सेसफुली प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कर
लिया एज ए रूट यूजर और अभी मैं इस मशीन के
अंदर कुछ भी कर सकता हूं क्योंकि मैं इस
मशीन का एडमिन यूजर हूं तो सक्सेसफुली
उसको हम सबमिट करते हैं और नाउ वी गट आवर
लास्ट फ्लैग और सबमिट एंड व सक्सेसफुली
कंप्लीट आवर लैब
ओके तो अभी किसी कोई डाउट रिलेटेड टू द
क्लास मुझसे पूछ सकते
हो यह हुआ कैसे टार क्या होता है
यह आपको पता करना चाहिए कमांड कैसे काम
करती है टार फाइल के बारे में लेकिन यह
आपको यह जीटीएफ और बिंस की हेल्प से आप
क्या कर सकते हो किसी भी क्योंकि देखो हर
रोज यह फाइल अपडेट होती है हर रोज यह
वेबसाइट अपडेट होती है हर रोज कोई ना कोई
वनटी आती है हर कुछ कोई ना कोई नया
एक्सप्लोइट आता है तो हर एक्सप्लोइट के
बारे में किसी भी पेन टेस्टर को नहीं पता
होगा बट आपको रेफरेंस पता होना चाहिए कहां
पर एक्सपर्ट चेक करना है टार के अंदर
वल्नरेबल थी इसलिए उसका फायदा उठाया आपने
और उसको रन कर लिया देखो टार हान सीएफ डेव
नल एक फाइल होती है उसके बाद न मतलब ये
इसके अंदर एक एक्सप्लोइट था अब इसको आप
सर्च करोगे चैट जीपीटी कहीं पर तब आपको इस
पर रिसर्च करने होगी त नहीं है तब इसने
क्या किया आपको एसएस सेल प्रोवाइड किया
ओके तो इसको हर किसी को किसी को नहीं पता
हो कौन सा एक्सट कैसे काम करता है यहां पर
यहां पर सिर्फ आपको एक्सप्लोइट मिल जाएंगे
तो अभी किसी का कोई सवाल मुझसे पूछ सकता
है एवरीवन
नेक्स्ट क्लास न पिकल रि सीटीएफ भा ऑलरेडी
हम कवर कर चुके इससे पहले जो सीटीएफ हुआ
था पिकल रि सीटीएफ हुआ
था नहीं जीटीएफ बीन द
बेस्ट गिट अप रिपोजिटरी इससे बेस्ट नहीं
है यही लिनक्स के लिए प द बेस्ट सर्च कैसे
किया
मैंने ार क्यों चूज किया क्योंकि सूडो
हाइन एल से हमें पता चला क्योंकि जो
नॉर्मल यूजर्स है वह ओनली टार कमांड को ही
एज ए रूट यूजर रन कर सकता है इसलिए हमने
टार को चूज
किया यू आर एब्सेंट फ्रॉम द प्रीवियस
क्लास तो इट्स इट्स नॉट माइन
प्रॉब्लम किसी और कोई सवाल है तो पूछ
लीजिए हमने एक को सीटीएफ लैब्स को
सक्सेसफुली परफॉर्म कर लिया यहां पर हमने
कुछ नए टूल्स का डिस्कशन किया है कुछ नए
टूल्स का यूसेज सीखा है और एक नई तरीके से
स्लैब को सॉल्व किया है सबको पता चल
गया कौन सा मेथड जीी एक रोड मैप होय आपको
खुद से बनाना
होगा यह आपको खुद से बनाना देखो हमारे
सामने इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती गई और इस
इंफॉर्मेशन को आप यूज करते गए उसके फर्द
आप इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करते गए उसको यूज
करते गए बस सिंपल आपको आगे बढ़ना है आपके
पास जितनी ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन होगी उतने
ज्यादा आप क्या कर सकते हो पेन टेस्ट कर
कर सकते
हो देखो एक चीज है मैं आपको एडवाइस करू
देखो कि पेंटेस्टिंग के केस में क्या होता
है ना कि आप टाइम बाउंड होते हो कि किसी
भी टारगेट के आप 6 घंटे 70 घंटे 80 घंटे
100 घंटे इससे ज्यादा पन टेस्टिंग आप नहीं
कर पाते क्योंकि आप थक जाते हो ओके आप थक
जाते हो इसलिए यह क्या
है टाइम बाउंड होती है तो इसलिए क्या है
आपको पन टेस्टिंग एक लेवल तक ही कर पाते
हो आप तो इसलिए आपको क्या है कि खुद के
अभी देखो आपने एक सवाल पूछा मुझसे कि सर
मैं रोड मैप क्या यूज कर रोड मैप तो आपका
चल रहा है मेथड आप हर क्लास में एक नई
मैथोलॉजी सीख रहे हो एक नया टूल आप सीख
रहे हो उसको जो जो लैब के हिसाब से आप
अपने खुद के शॉर्ट नोट क्रिएट कीजिए अभी
यह नोट तो आपको क्रिएट करने होंगे यह तो
स्पून फीडिंग नहीं कर सकता मैं आपके लिए
यह आपको खुद से क्रिएट करने होंगे और फर्द
सीटीएफ सॉल्व करने के लिए आपको प्रैक्टिस
करनी होगी
तो आप लोगों का टास्क है जो आपको परफॉर्म
करनी है उस लैब का नाम है यह रहा आपके
सामने बैक कर देते हैं ओके
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नो नो नो नो आई
एम नॉट इंटरेस्टेड तो के
बैक यह रहा यह रहा डेलन और आज का आपका
टास्क है जो आपको परफॉर्म करना है
दिमाग काम नहीं कर रहा क्यों काम नहीं कर
रहा कोई नहीं आपका दिमाग काम कर जाएगा
जैसे जैसे क्लास में आगे बढ़ेंगे हम आपका
दिमाग काम करेगा आपको जो लैब सॉल्व करनी
है उसका नाम है बुकली
99 बुकली
नाना यह रही यह भी जीजी लैंग्वेज है
लिनक्स मशीन है प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
परफॉर्म करना है यूजर फ्लैग और रूट फ्लैग
आपको फाइंड आउट करने हैं यह आपका टारगेट
है और बिफोर नेक्स्ट क्लास मैं चाहता हूं
कि आप लोग आप सब लोग इसको सॉल्व करें ओके
और मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में सॉल्व करके आपको
दिखा दूंगा आप लोगों से पूछूंगा गाइडेंस
आप लोगों से लूंगा ओके इसके अंदर जो दो
तरीके से मैं आपको हिंट दे रहा हूं इसको
दो तरीके से सॉल्व किया जाता है पहला
तरीका स्टैगो ग्राफी जो स्टेक एनालिसिस है
उसको मत ट्राई करना उसको मैं सिखाऊंगा और
जो दूसरा तरीका है इन दो लैब्स की टेक्निक
को यूज करके आप इसको सॉल्व कर सकते
हो हो
जाएगा हा यह फ्री वाला है अभी तक जितनी भी
लैब मैंने आपको करवाई है सारी की सारी
फ्री लैब है तो य मैं आपको शेयर कर देता
हूं इसका
लिंक ऑल आर फ्री
लब्स यर आप इसको सॉल्व कर सकते हो किसी का
कोई सवाल मुझसे पूछ सकते हो नेक्स्ट न
मिनट में उसके बाद हम क्या कर देंगे सेशन
को एंड कर देंगे अदर वाइज आपका कोई भी
सवाल नहीं होगा तो आई होप सबने क्लास में
एंजॉय किया होगा नई नई चीजें आप सीख रहे
होंग क्योंकि लिनक्स प्रिज एस्केलेशन आज
तक कोई पढ़ाता मतलब किसी ने पढ़ाया होगा
तो इतने अच्छे तरीके से नहीं पढ़ाया होगा
इस तरीके से नहीं पढ़ाया हो और लिनक्स
प्रिविलेज एलेशन का एक जस्ट डेमो था यह
क्योंकि देखो प्रिविलेज एस्की लेसन अपने
आप में एक बहुत बड़ा टॉपिक है लेकिन मैं
आपको कंप्लीट टॉपिक तो नहीं पढ़ा सकता न
आप लोगों को आदत डाल सकता हूं आप लोगों को
मैं तरीके बता सकता हूं लेकिन अगर आपको
कंप्लीट प्रिविलेज एस्क लेशन सीखना होगा
तो उसके लिए हम बूट कैंप लेकर आएंगे बूट
कैंप में आप क्या कर सकते
हो एक जवाइन कर सकते हो और जवाइन करके
कंप्लीट प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन सीख सकते हो
नक्स के ऊपर या विंडोज के ऊपर दोनों के
ऊपर ओके नेक्स्ट क्लास जल्दी हम करेंगे तो
सबसे पहले आपको इस टास्क को सॉल्व करना है
तभी हम क्या करें नेक्स्ट क्लास में कोई
नई लैब तभी लेकर आएंगे अगर आप यह टास्क
सॉल्व कर पाओगे ओके हो जाएगा य टास्क
एवरीवन बूट कैंप का प्राइस आप लोग डिफाइन
कर लेना बता दिया ना ट हैक कैसे करें सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करके आप हैक कर सकते
हो या दूसरा तरीका आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग करनी पड़ेगी उसके अंदर
लूप होल फाइंड आउट करने होंगे उस कोड को
मैनिपुलेट करना होगा देन अकॉर्डिंग टू नीड
उसको यूज करना होगा दो तरीकों से कर सकते
हो आप ट को हैक करना या आप कर सकते
हो ओके थैंक यू मान सिंह
शर्मा नेक्स्ट क्लास कब
होगी नेक्स्ट क्लास यार आप लोगों पर
ज्यादा डिप मैं फ्रीक्वेंसी
में आज ही देखिए आप स्टूडेंट्स आए नहीं
वह मुझे कुछ मानते ही
नहीं हो जाएगा बहुत इजी लैंग्वेज है मतलब
सॉरी बहुत इजी लैब है यह सीटीएफ है अब दो
जो आपने क्या किया ना सीटीएफ वन और सीटीएफ
टू अगर आपको सही से समझ में आ गया होगा तो
इन्हीं टूल्स और इ टेक्निक्स की हेल्प से
इसको सॉल्व कर लोगे
आप नहीं अखिलेश में फ्रीक्वेंसी
मुझे स्टूडेंट्स पर विश्वास नहीं है
अभी स्ट आते नहीं
यार तो आप लोग फ्री फायर कीजिए कोई नहीं
हम भी फ्री फायर खेल रहे हैं लाइफ का फ्री
फायर खेल रहे
हैं तो आप धीरे-धीरे कवर कीजिए वेरी गुड
आपको लेने बहुत काम आएगा
अभी और शायद मान सिंह को समझ में आ गया
हान एल कहां से आई होगी फिर मानसिक समझ
में
आया चलिए फिर हम सेशन को एंड करते हैं
और बाय बाय गुड नाइट आप लोग कोई सवाल नहीं
है टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन
गुड नाइट